Speaker 1: Let's go next. Where where are we going
next here? What about I don't know? How about
Billy from Jersey? Billy, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, Billy.
Speaker 2: OK, quick question,
please. Can you describe to me what a woman
is giving? Actually, my question is when you
think of somebody who is radical and behavior.
It's somebody who may be erratic. How would you
describe a radical type of a person?
Speaker 1: Is it an erratic radical?
Speaker 2: I. Decisions they make and things
they do, because at a Trump rally come out,
the former president will say a radical
do nothing Democrats in the same sentence,
right? Which means they're all over the place,
but they're also doing completely nothing.
Speaker 1: Billy, there's a crazy squealing in the
background, and it sounds like you got a TV on.
And it sounds like you're on speaker. Is there,
can you? Can you help us out here? So we're on the
same team rather than on opposite teams?
Speaker 2: So sorry. With See?
Speaker 1: So, Billy, tell me, is this
like a word game or a political question
I'm trying to figure out, are we just playing
games with the words erratic and radical or
what's going on?
Speaker 2: Oh.
Just. It's when you call
somebody a radical. Oh boy.
Speaker 1: All right, Billy, I'm going to let
you go, Wow, it's crazy what's happening over
at Billy's place. It's it's really it's quite a
scene. It's hard to even keep up with all of it.